cologne is all about modern art right
now the art cologne is the world's
oldest art fair with some 200 exhibitors
it can be overwhelming but one person in
particular is keeping an eye on all the
movement at the fair distimo yet so
beautiful ones in the mood is very
focused like racehorses right before a
race hmm they're very focused because
it's about money from kids hans maya is
one of the cofounders of the art cologne
it premiered in 1967 as the cologne art
market this year the 75 year old is
being honored for his effort with the
art cologne prize the art fair has
changed greatly over the past 50 years
growing in size and global reach things
were very different in the early days he
says play me teeth it was very primitive
we were in a smaller hole and everyone
had maybe 30 square meters of display
space everyone just took the pictures
off the walls of their galleries and
hung them in their space we had a lot of
fun pants Maya is in the top league of
art dealers he opened his first gallery
in 1965 in the southern german town of
esslingen at the age of 25 theater
events and concerts have been a part of
his exhibitions from the beginning at 60
calories when I had the gallery in
esslingen the art historians and a lot
of museum folks said for heaven's sake
there's this crazy guy in s Ling and
putting on exhibitions with rock music
and the police are always being called
in it was just a revolt against the
establishment including the established
art business italia from quince handle
that got the attention of the
international art world in the late
1960s hans maya moved to disel Dorf he
was the first gallerist in germany to
show works by Andy Warhol and introduced
him to the German action artist Yosef
boys when
see idea I was putting on an exhibition
and I said two boys he should come to
the opening because Warhol would be
there and he said why and I said you've
got a show in New York next year and
you'd be happy if he showed up so that's
how they met and they basically got
along really well right from the start
Christie's cord Meyer brought one
important contemporary artist after
another to Germany Keith Haring for
instance painted a sports car just for
him Meyer likes photography too Helmut
Newton had his first show with him and
shortly before his death in 2004 his
last one to Maya's daughter Marie is
also now involved in the business she
shares her father's love of arts
maybe somebody with your dad I remember
very well that Jean tangley often
visited us and he had two dachshunds
that were not e'en loud and I was really
angry with those dogs of Lord one on
each Alaskan those are the moments i
have vivid memories of men to the boy
sometimes called time at nine come Marie
Meyer has also inherited her father's
keen eye for new talents like South
African artists Xander Blum whose
pictures are currently on display in the
gallery and a tart Cologne lungs works
costs around 10,000 euros artwork that
Hans Meyer previously sold for a few
thousand marks are now changing hands
for several million euros just one room
photos you couldn't have predicted that
art would reach this price category if I
had known how important Gerhard Arista
or Andy Warhol would become then I'd
have filled my cellar with Warhol's or
wristers or polkas or whatever but
there's no way to predict that there's a
huge demand for works by artists like
them but the chance of getting hold of a
leash duro Warhol are slim and that's
where another of meijer talents comes
into play he knows what his clients want
and shows them what he thinks they might
like Manny mallomar because sometimes
the clients are a bit taken aback by how
well I know them by today 10 or 15
people will come and just look at one or
two or three pictures I know that's why
would a tribal on shown no one can
predict who is going to be the next Andy
Warhol or Roy Lichtenstein but that's
what makes art cologne so exciting
alongside the big names there are lots
of little known artists whose work may
one day be worth twice or three times
what it is now
you